so my title is a little different than
what I gave in the sheet with advertises
the day because I was thinking that
about sort of the whole day sort of
interesting to think about it as how
very basic science kind of researched it
was done in a very theoretical setting a
maybe 3040 years before it people saw
the application of it comes to fruition
and the sort of um basic idea to impact
it's going to be more the focus of my
talk and so it's going to be kind of a
survey of a bunch of things that we've
seen here but sort of a point of view of
how it went from an invention early on
to usage today and I also talked a
little bit about what's being done now
in terms of taking some basic technology
from the past some basic ideas to apply
them for problems in machine learning
and probably in this age of big data
okay so and I just want to say that this
talk is a based to some extent on a talk
that I gave in front of Congress or at
least represented in Congress in DC it's
part of an effort of the of MSRI Science
Research Institute to convince Congress
that money should be devoted to basic
research was of its importance so this
is a high-level talk which i think is
good given the hour and so think of
yourself as a bunch of people in
Congress that don't know a lot of
photography but you are willing to learn
a so this is the level so I apologize
that it's not talking about anything
technical that Clara says or what do you
call them CPRS those VCRs VCRs okay
all right so so the beginning of this
talk is really the fact that I was a
graduate at Berkeley in the 80s and now
as many years later but in the process
of this I've really been an eyewitness
to a lot of very surprising consequences
of research and I sort of a witnessed
firsthand
starting from public key cryptography
which everybody knows its impact on
electronic commerce if you don't know it
really is behind everything you were
doing online these days a transactions
like getting things out of your bank
accounts of purchases online and so
forth it's all powered by the belief
that people cannot essentially steal
your money or pretend to be you when
they're making transactions and then
there is cryptocurrencies that people
talked about there's there an author on
quantum computations that two must talk
about as in its basis this idea that
what the computers can be built which
again is kind of tremendous that we are
at this era where people actually
seriously talking about they're
seriously talking about changing the
whole interface of Trani commerce to one
that's gonna be quantum resilient
whereas only I can remember when sort of
finance proposing this idea of a quantum
computer it's own paper right and now we
are in this age where we are worried
about it I mean we're all so excited but
also worried about what the impact will
be on electronic commerce and other
basic ideas which have nothing to do
with cryptography really things like
content distribution using clever
algorithms for distributing content very
quickly like Akamai type algorithms that
come from distributed algorithms which
really come from a theoretical
inventions of people working on some
abstract graphs with some abstract model
of conflict in traffic which they didn't
even really imagine could be true but
then it was the case yeah I think the
story of Akamai is that there was Super
Bowl and there's all these people who
were trying to advertise and everybody
was logging in to see the Super Bowl and
everything crashed and the only the way
that this was the kind of Salvage is
because the people who use Akamai and
that's really what gave them their their
leverage in going to market but it
really was a paper in one of these Fox
our theory conference and then Google
you know it's pay based search are based
on the PageRank algorithm which again is
a really a theoretical algorithm to
begin with having to do with expander
graphs and so forth but it's made its
way to what we use everybody uses today
and the reason that I have a picture of
cloud computing is because as was
mentioned I think in maybe intimacies
talk is this whole idea that you want to
delegate computation to a more powerful
computer
we could be a quantum computer could be
also just a classical computer in the
cloud that has a lot more strength and
these days everybody's saying about
putting their computations in the cloud
but there's a basic question there but
how are you assure that the cloud is
doing the computations correctly there's
also a question of privacy how do you
make sure that you can harvest the
computational power of the cloud without
giving all your data away so the
question is how do you do this
efficiently how do you verify
computations the cloud how you make sure
that privacy is not compromised and ways
to do that efficiently again are based
on fairly basic complexity type work on
proof systems efficient verification so
I really think that all these major I I
feel safe saying that all these major
advances have come about due to basic
research and in some sense you can think
about the next I guess 10 minutes we
want to get the reception at 4 but let's
say the next 20 minutes is trying to
convince you that this is really true
maybe it's really going to the convert
but if you your congressmen and women
maybe you need to be convinced so so
what characterizes basic research here
you know really this is again we all
know is that in my definition it's
driven by curiosity it's not because we
got a DARPA grant and we have to the
deliverables and and really the
consequences of it sometimes you know
they cannot be imagined in a day in
advance that's not why you're doing it
the somewhat unimaginable and I think
that if you think about sort of these
basic crypto and where they are at it
really is kind of unimaginable how far
this has gone and the bottom line that
we're trying to do in Congress and the
truth is also for companies supporting
research like of the type of the
assignments Institute is that from a
very small grant and a lot of this
research was done with some you know
$100,000 investment by NSF you can
eventually really get to multi-million
dollar billion dollar industries and
these are you know kind of remarks that
usually dislike but they're true in the
case that we're talking about all right
so what are the type of so I you know
that many fields one could discuss what
I know about is cryptography and if I
could there's lots of stories one can
tell but here are sort of five stories
public key cryptography zero knowledge
proof you've heard about
so these were invented in the 80s and it
was much
I think only now now talk about this in
more detail in the talk you're seeing
how they are really being taken
advantage of in blockchains like like
Ali talked about a private delegation to
the clown in forensics this is not
really being used but you can at least
see according to Ben's talk the use of
it a post quantum cryptography a and
which actually Daniel actually touched
on and other people that some of the
assumptions that were using these days
are resistant to cryptography it took
compare the quantum strength blockchains
and something we didn't touch about
which is how to do multi-party
computation so the point of this slide
really is that here are five inventions
okay which ship started really without
any connection to practice in fact
they've started so many years ago and we
thirty forty years ago but today people
are talking about this pragmatically as
if this is going to enable something
that we don't know how to do and and
they're building these systems so you
know it's I think they all come under
this this title of the talk which is
idea to impact coming-of-age and I'll
tell you a little bit about each one of
them really a little bit and I guess the
second thing I want to say is that even
though we're sitting here it's 2019 and
each of these talks I was isolated from
each other I haven't got I've even seen
this from the get-go there's really a
narrative there's sort of story how
these things build upon each other and I
like stories so I'm gonna tell this as a
story okay so we in the story starts
really in the most basic story is that
and this has nothing to do with modern
cryptography but it's always that we
think that the basic story of
cryptography there's Alice and Bob door
to party the sender and a receiver a
message wants to be transmitted but
there's somebody that's listening on the
line the most basic problem of
cryptography right is that we want to
encrypt these messages and classically
this is done by these Alice and Bob
meeting they can decide on the key and
based on these key they encrypt and sort
of the big departure from this which
starts this whole story of modern
cryptography
is this work of diffie-hellman I just
want to sort of start the story in the
beginning where they really come up with
this incredible notion of public key
cryptography which starts this whole
field off hey where they give us this
blueprint this wish list that there's
gonna be this way that alice is gonna be
able to send messages to Bob without
ever meeting him so they don't have to
agree on a key but somehow there's gonna
be this magical thing they hope okay
over lock in a key right so there's
going to be a public lock which everyone
could send messages and lock by locking
their message but there's only one
person this Bob what is it Alice in my
sending to whom good so it's Bob that
knows the key
so they're saying wouldn't be nice if
they were this way to lock in a way to
open a so therefore everybody could send
messages to one person who could open
them and in fact they didn't really they
really didn't have an instantiation of
it but so this is the but they the first
instantiation is this next paper by
public by RSA Rivest Shamir and Adleman
in MIT were they saying that this can be
realized using number theory and this
everybody knows right this is the RSA
cryptosystem where in a sense the lock
is some product of primes you know some
large number everybody sees this number
and based on that they can send messages
but only the person who knows the
factorization in a sense has this
analogous key and can open what was
locked and read the messages okay so
that's the story it's beautiful we won't
get into details how that's done but
this does really cement this transition
of internet from primary military to
primary commercial and if we go back to
my first picture you know I think that
the RSA was based on there was a patent
that they wrote let me they had a very
very small grant from NSF which was
intended for something completely
different I think to do graph algorithms
and they did this and that's why I think
we should ask for money for X and then
we feel completely permitted to do not X
or Y because sometimes in fact usually
it probably is better than what we set
out to do so these guys they wrote this
patent and and then
this is a merge to a billion-dollar
industry for certificates and so forth
still being used today on the internet
even though these this pattern is
expired and in terms of how much time it
took to go from idea to that's a patent
even okay it took a long time so the
idea is like in 1976 I said 1982 they
started the patenting process it took
many many years till about 2009 that
they got a patent for it
yes that's what our say specifically
okay so if you look at this is from Jim
beets awesome Ron so it's all you know
so apparently there was public key
cryptography but RSA baseball he could
throw if he takes that much time I know
the pattern of the patent the standard
sorry sorry sorry I misused the word so
this is standardization the patent is
one thing the other thing is to have it
as a standard so the process of getting
it is a standard took many many years it
started early it took a very long time a
lot of hurdles along the way and in 2009
he was actually mentioned as a standard
sorry and there are lots of explanations
of why it's such a long history maybe it
market wasn't new wasn't ready for it
there wasn't a killer application the
standard bodies weren't used to this
type of standard but the my point of
this is not so much that you look at
this individual boxes is that it took a
very long time to go from basic idea to
standard even though the impact was
already done in the middle yes no are
you looking at the boxes okay okay so
meanwhile in the physics world which is
just so we're continuing our story which
I think too much talk about this is
right is that Fineman is inventing this
powerful quantum computer on paper and
Peter shor says you know what with your
quantum computer that's written on paper
I'm gonna factor integers also on paper
and oh that's very interesting so on
paper it's all basic research is all
done in theory papers in a sense either
physics theory or computer science
theory because in practice we know the
quantum computers can factor very large
numbers although now I understand we can
generate random numbers I mean it's a
different thing about quantum key
distribution quantum computing and yet
again I think you must
they talked about it is now becoming
more and more of you know there's
certainly a lot of money invested in it
and certainly people are worried enough
so that they are preparing for this post
quantum age where you can't use
factoring and because it will be broken
and I thought the Daniel's idea was
extremely interesting or the person's
paper you quoted which is saying well
these Quantico Peter is gonna be built
at some point and so we maybe we can do
applications today there are safe
against Quantico piers that will be
built in the future somehow based the
privacy about some future event but use
it have a usability in the present I
think I think that's a fascinating idea
so my point here is that we seem to be
stuck because there'll be these quantum
computers and everything is going to be
broken but is they Daniel II said I tie
for a completely different purpose
because he wanted to what he worried
about worst case and average case
problems and I want to show Tom which is
hard in the worst case as much as in the
average case completely theoretical
disarray other desi Dorada
okay which is not motivated by quantum
this or that or the other said why don't
we use geometry those computation those
lattices that are Daniel II described
and the problems and lattices like
finding a short vector finding a closed
vector is a sort of a hard problem to
solve just like the factoring problems
hard it's another hard problem right he
says let's base let's do that is our
basis is over hard problem and then it
turned out this is the book of Daniel in
complexity of lattice problems where the
I thought it's just geometry this is
very interesting the theoreticians and
as we Xterra Titian start playing with
it and showing you know actually this
geometry is not a in the beginning it
looks much less usable than the
factoring problem because it's harder we
don't know how to work with vectors and
geometry we know how to work with
numbers but it turns out that actually
you can do a lot more with it as far as
we can tell you can do from a morphic
encryption you can do something called
functional encryption it's it's
interesting that it has seems to have a
lot more power than the number the
classic number theory and in addition to
that it has a theoretical basis that
motivated I tried to work on it to begin
with and the third
is that it actually seems not to be
breakable by quantum computers now that
could be is because we don't understand
these problems well enough whatever the
reason is right now we don't know how to
break it okay so in some sense we have
gotten quantum resilient or the way I'd
like to say it we've gotten a solution
to a problem that we didn't know we're
going to have just because we worried
about theory so people can say well this
is accidental but you know how many
accidents can you have you know so I
think about my career so accidents but
in the end it's not bad so so so same
here you know so from theory you can
solve problems they come up in practice
later I would say that's enough evidence
to to do theory so just I wanted to say
one things will be something technical
here and it's that I only talked about
lattices and here this room I took
pictures but there's another way to
think of its equivalent to this lattice
problems that donator talked about and
this is this problem called learning
with errors they think to must mention
this problem I just wanted to mention
what that is so learning with errors is
a problem where you have a secret which
is just a vector of numbers in zqn so
the numbers are like the secret is s 1 s
2 s 3 S 4 these n numbers mark you and
and what you say is what's true about
these numbers what pins them down is the
fact that there's a bunch of equations
these numbers satisfy ok and so what you
give everybody in the world to look at
is the coefficients of these equations
on the right-hand side and also the
solutions on the left-hand side of
course if you go in the exact solution
they could do Gaussian elimination
so you give noisy solutions and it turns
out if I give you these equations and
some in some noisy solutions then it's a
hard problem to find this s 1 s 2 up to
SN this problem is equivalent even
though it's very hard to see why to
these problems that Daniel talked about
these geometry problems of finding a
short vector or closed vector equivalent
in some formal sense ok that if you can
solve one then you can solve the other
and it's if and only if so how nosy is
important right it you take some guy
except for some Gaussian noise and you
add to it how noisy depends really on
the kind of approximation factor
[Music]
all right so a little bit depends on
approximation if you could ask two
questions how noisy for the purpose of
cryptography and how noisy for the
purpose of reduction with the geometry
but let's say the square root of n 4 is
for the purpose you are interested in
folk of geography and this is why is
this better than number theory I don't
say it's better but for right now we
don't know how to break it with quantum
computers secondly the best algorithm we
know is actually much classical one is
much slower than the bone to factor and
slower is good in our world because
slower for the adversary which sort of
means that you can use smaller numbers
rather than larger numbers since it
takes more time in the size of your
dimension so there's our advantage to
this kind of problem and this is what
this post quantum or at least currently
post quantum which is an interesting way
to define it currently quantum resilient
cryptography is based on so again the
punchline is the basic research from 20
30 years ago is going to save us from a
problem we never knew we'd have already
said the punch line what about this the
fact that I'm saying that there is from
impact so there's been a standardization
call by this National Institute of
Standards it's already close by now
where they said we want to do have
public key cryptography digital
signatures key exchange all based on
this new type of crypto which Quantum's
can break most of the proposals are
based on these lattices for learning
with errors and from all over the world
ok the next so this is the story for
this not exactly in the same order but
their knowledge then whereas in the
first problem Alice and Bob want to send
private messages
now we're talking about sent occasion
she wants to prove to him that she's
Alice
he's like Amazon she wants to buy
something from him and and the fear is
that if she sends the password over
right in Amazon is just now compared her
the locally stored password with her
password the problem is that these are
break-ins let's say might be a problem
there's lot of break-ins in to Amazon
obviously 1986 we didn't think about
Amazon and breaking into Amazon's but
couched in today's reality we can think
of this as the problem so the question
is how do you prevent this how is Amazon
going to store I was honest actually
should talk about Facebook how space
we're gonna store my passwords in such a
way that I can be confident that he
won't
be leaked you know actually it's a
fabulous example and the answer is I
won't trust them so so the question then
is is there a way that ours can prove to
a Facebook that she knows the password
without ever giving it so could it be
that Facebook actually it's not gonna
get it I'm not gonna hold my passwords
and they can still verify to me that's
really the question and zero knowledge
enables you to prove that you know
something okay and you're the only one
who knows it if you generated your
password and then you deposit it it's in
some form in public form that everybody
can look at other people can't because
they don't know the password so this Z
or not of course has to be cut the kind
that Amazon should be sure that it's me
and furthermore that maybe somebody
who's if Amazon sees it many times they
still can't tell what my password is and
store it or anybody watching these
messages cannot tell cannot imitate to
be me and so forth and say or not gives
you all these properties and this is
this paper with Silvio and Charlie
Rakoff but the knowledge complexity of
attractive proof system the idea being
is somehow that the verifier I'm as a
Amazon is going to be able to generate
some randomly difficult mathematical
challenges we don't tell you how but
they can generate some random
mathematical challenges that only the
one who knows the password or knows this
secret when I was the proof consultant
okay so if you know the proof if you're
the right person who knows that post to
some theorem or the past we think about
passwords as proofs two theorems then
you can solve those challenges and each
time you log in they generate new
challenges you can solve these new
challenges and since they never generate
the same challenges somebody can't just
watch it and answer the question their
answers you answered before they have to
solve new challenges this is one way to
abstract what's happening in zero
knowledge so this enables access
authorization without fear of identity
theft but really a where as in 85 when
we came out with this it seemed like
identity theft pointed out by Sameer and
Fiat Fiat and Sameer say gay it was good
for identity theft we actually were just
talking about theorems and proofs and we
had no idea there was any application
here but they pointed out this is a way
to prevent identity theft
these days you know they're things like
the nuclear disarmament at least their
papers written about it it's not just
papers there's actually grant there's
large grants given to different
universities for this nuclear
disarmament idea based on your knowledge
there's this forensic idea but more
concretely there's zero cash the crypto
currency which is based on this idea of
zero knowledge where you're trying to
prove is consistency between transfers
of accounts right that you haven't spent
money or if you have spent it you can't
double spend it and so forth without
telling the details of what the
transactions are and not only that but
there's even application now for for
surveillance so if we think about a
court system that apparently does this
issue where there's many many many
surveillance orders that are being
awarded these days by federal judges and
there's really no accounting of whether
how large a problem this is there's no
accounting of whether you know these
things to actually be there's some gag
orders on these and secrecy orders and
I'm supposed to be lifted and they don't
lift it the whole thing is unrealized
unwith out sort of any guidance and you
could imagine the or not also playing a
role there for accounting of the court
system that they're actually behaving
according to what they supposed to all
right so this is again a case where
unfortunately we didn't patent but
somebody else is making money on it so
but we could have so there was a
publication and all right and in terms
of standardization you know there was a
workshop last year and there was a
workshop that just ended yesterday
there's zero knowledge zero knowledge
proof workshop for getting standardized
so remember we talked about our say
taking such a long time I think this is
taking even longer mostly because the
people behind that didn't started the
standardization of effort for about 30
years
but now they'd started we hope it's not
going to take another 19 whatever it was
over there years to get accomplished so
just continue the story what about these
block chains so people know this paper
or some of you know this paper of
Bitcoin by some Doshi a people don't
know who is this also gives I think it's
a good idea to write paper when people
don't know who you are because it gives
you certainly not me so again it gives
romantic aspect to this whole thing who
is or she who they are whatever at this
point is a bite it's a a okay but and it
seems like a miracle Wow but there is
some history to this and in fact there's
some sort of a paper they talked about
that academic pedigree already it wasn't
born out of nothing okay so there are
works that have been developed in
cryptography years before that make
their way into this paper and what are
some of these works so there is this
paper by Dworkin or in 1992 where they
said you know this is the time people
start to get spam spam emails and now
you wanted to kind of reduce it and this
before spam filters were really the way
to go and they said let's make it so
that anybody sends me a message has to
do some work okay some computational
work so he won't be worth for the
Spanish to do so much work so and
therefore they won't be sending me
messages so they have this is where this
notion of proof of working surprising
via processing or comeback the junk mail
and Microsoft are essentially I don't
know if they implemented that ever I
never went anywhere but in Satoshi is
what but it never but it's not used it
is used in every commercialized sorry so
it went somewhere but it wasn't
commercialized and yet in in the Bitcoin
paper that's the idea right how do you
prove that you get to post you do a lot
of work and whoever does more work or is
more lucky in the last if they do
exactly the same amount of work posts so
again proof of work is kind of the way
to arbitrate a or to way to incentivize
posting properly so that's the proof of
work that's not enough there's also the
idea of time stamping so sort of that
you know the current work that you are
doing is based on on the past and you
can't change the order of the blocks
right because it's all based on next one
is based on the history and this is sort
of time stamping built on what's called
miracle trees from 1987 and a
paperweight Stuart Harbor where he
proposed this idea that in the New York
Times there will be a hash of everything
that was posted before and if you want
to put something in The New York Times
or the next day you have to sort of
compute a function on that hash and that
way you won't be able to say I
ten years before because I was only
posted ten years later the thing you
were supposed to compute an - Shawn
and then in Sylvia said also for his
idea this proof of stake right or what
he called perfect pure pure proofs of
stake then it's not talking about the
proofs of work but he or timestamping
but he's talking about also times that
Venus in some sense is there because
doing a hash of the whole block train
but he's talking a Byzantine agreement
Byzantine agreement again this is the
bread and butter of distributed
computing lots of work from 1982 to
build on so there's a lot of research
here that was done completely for
different purposes really for academic
study that have made their way into this
incredible industry of blockchains and
micro payments and even though people
say and Sylvia himself said there's no
really blockchain and we talk about it
but doesn't exist yet it's clear that
it's certainly generating a lot of
income just for someone and it will and
it will exist I mean there's still good
of an idea and too good of an
application and it's based on this
academic work so what are some
applications medical record leakage of
course currency transparency and
record-keeping accountability this is
about the surveillance that I talked
about before that there's also a way
that the block chains actually could
play a role there all right so another
thing that happened with these block
chains which is sort of ties me to the
rest of the to the day is that because
of such an interest in block chains it's
sort of an opportunity to take all these
cryptographic techniques that we've
generated over the last 3040 years and
to make sure the people pay attention
you're saying you like block chains let
me tell you what you can do with block
chains and this is something we knew how
to do thirty years earlier and
regardless of what this perverse mode of
thinking it's a good outcome so for
example okay so for example so these
days so this is almost the end of my
talk so I've talked about almost
everything that was on my first outline
but I didn't talk about one of the
middle which is this idea of multi-party
computation and homomorphic encryption
so these days we're not just are doing
encryption or authentication or let's
say block chains
one of the things we're in a big store
the big story is data right there's all
this data out there and using all this
data we can do analytics you know we can
do threat prediction we can do better
infrastructure and so forth okay and
part of you know the premise of this is
that essentially people are storing or
source or accidentally storing because
you use your apps and if somebody
collects information on you is that all
this information is going to some third
party so I want to think of this the
pictures just a cloud so there's
unprecedented collection of private data
and it's a wonderful thing in terms of
utility for lots of it car lots of lots
of areas health financial market traffic
rerouting smart energy use speech and
envision recognition and often this
requires very large data sets so maybe
Google has them all but sometimes we
want to share data sets so large records
are supposed to be better and in most
applications they are so there's some
problem here it's how to incentivize
people to share data sets and how do we
take advantage of data of individuals
without actually finding out their data
and this is really the problem where
that can be addressed if everybody sent
everybody else their data but again as
you know if you hold somebody's data and
then you're broken into you're liable
it's a toxic asset in some sense so
there is this balance between the
utility we can get out of data and the
liability from holding data and this all
is really being addressed by math again
math it was developed to some extent in
the 80s and is being improved these days
so what are some techniques something
called secure multi-party computation
from the 80s homomorphic encryption that
Anila mentioned from 2008 and why it
started with gentry it was a graduation
at Stanford then and searchable
encryption which is much somewhat later
invention all of these things can be
that these two things are really lattice
based where is the first secure
multi-party computation is something
much much older before the lattices and
just really a few more slides the idea
here is a picture is this data stored in
that many different places they all will
compute a function on it the function
could be analytics
the rerouting traffic for each one of us
a car driving places but they don't
trust each other and they want to be
able to come up with the conclusions
without telling each other the data and
the theorem says that it can be done and
it can be done either if these two can
communicate in complete privacy or so
think about it can be done factoring is
hard or learning with errors is hard if
we want a quantum resistant so if some
problems are hard to crack you can do
this you can compute on an aggregate of
data without revealing each other the
data and what is this what is this good
for so let's let me skip the technology
there's also standardization of some of
this stuff so here are some applications
of people who already use it for in some
applications maybe people could use it
for so in terms of financial markets
people it's been used for auctions this
is in Denmark doing sugarbeets auction
this is the most amazing story for some
reason in Denmark I don't know why but
these people who want to sell sugar
beets are very technologically advanced
and they don't want to and they want to
do this in a way that's multi-party
computation where people don't know what
each other's price varies and there's a
it is really because there are this this
company which is a bunch of very smart
cryptographers in Denmark and then in
Estonia is another place that have
offered this technology and their people
are intrapreneurial enough to say well
you know there's this technology let's
try it out for market clearinghouse like
match incoming orders with prices from
trade from different traders for credit
rating of customers for coming up with
benchmarks and to see whether you're
above or below a benchmark and how do
you come up with a benchmark you have
information from a multiple of parties
and you compute let's say an average or
something then you compare yourself to
the average and also another application
that the Estonian tax and customs board
is done is for the 80 tax because in VT
tax you know there's what comes in
should equal to what comes out and so
and they have to check that in fact in
the case so this is in terms of
financial markets people are going to be
interested these slides are going to be
available and actually this slide is a
thanks to my uncle professor in BO and
the next three slides are actually from
him another place that this was deployed
is or at least there's a proposal for
deployment it's for electricity markets
where let's say there's a bunch of
dealers and people who offer electricity
and people and a bunch of consumers and
the consumers let's say don't want to
say how much they consumes the the
people are offering the electricity are
sort of competing with each other in
order to make sure that they will be
chosen in order to provide the
electricity
so there's many parties here and they've
deployed they've proposed multi-party
computation solution which preserves
privacy for local electricity trading so
this is a system that's built another
place which is automation which is very
very different is a proposal to use
multi-party computation to avoid
satellite collisions so it seems again
kind of far out there but apparently is
interest from the government for this so
let's say there are satellites by
different governments and they are you
know in space and they don't want to
tell each other where the locations are
but they want to make sure that they
don't collide so they want so their
inputs are where the locations are the
output is where to go in such a way that
you don't collide and there's a paper on
this as well about how to avoid
collision what's another example is map
routing so there's another automation is
how do you get the shortest path in such
a way that takes into account the
traffic but doesn't people tell where
you they're at but they don't
necessarily so that you could benefit
and get the shortest path but they don't
want you to figure out exactly how
you're driving so there's another system
that was proposed for that
privacy-preserving shortest path
computation another place is in medical
so this is not really in my opinion
being used yet but obviously will and
that is where you have medical expertise
say some hospital that has developed a
model for diagnosis based on a lot of
patient information they're not supposed
to give patient information they might
not even supposed to give the model
because you could maybe reverse patient
information but there are patients let's
say in rural hospitals with with MRIs
with scans with whatever and they want
to be able to use the model so there's a
clear question here on both sides have
security concerns they want to hide the
model they want to hide the data how can
they interact sort of to
satisfy both security concerns so this
is a two-party computation which is sort
of a special case in fact the first case
of multi-party computation and you know
some original paper with Lou Caputo is
also professor here and others we showed
how to do this for simple learning
models not for neural nets efficiently
using some building blocks from
cryptography and then there's a recent
paper by there's a bunch of papers but
this is particular paper that I like by
you know they could to Nathan Sherlock
and another check out Xander probably
mispronouncing the name but in any case
where they show how to do this for
neural nets so they get performance
which is not bad for how to solve that
hospital and patient problem where the
model is a neural net you've come back
okay so in any case yeah think I don't
see okay and then another thing which I
think is really being I paid a lot of
attention to in Google and so forth is
this and this is a picture from their
from a paper from Google is this idea of
federated learning that is how can let's
say Google get learn from a lot of users
data in such a way that it they update
their models for text prediction but
they don't find out exactly what your
input is and there's lots of different
assumptions here but what Google
controls what they know what they don't
know how efficient it is again what's
the multi party car party computation
you can think about all the users who
might be doing a multi-party computation
or in their inputs and just give Google
the output so that it can update its
model of course that's a huge amount of
users so you want to do it efficiently
you want to choose subsets of the users
you don't really want to do multi-party
computation updated model is a specific
computation or you might be able to bank
on that it's a big field very
interesting and you know and one very
interesting question is why are they
doing it anyway
I mean is it for public relations is it
really because they don't want to hold
on to your data I think that's a
fascinating question it probably could
drive probably which solutions will be
adopted and not adopted
but you are a big company how many of
you like privacy what about sort of more
public good thing a so there was this
company this Boston thing which is again
was for publicity but it's a very
interesting project where they wanted to
talk about wage disparity so they're
saying are women and men getting the
same average salary and if not how was
the difference so they convinced all
these companies to go through a
multiparty protocol for average salary
now technically it's extremely simple
they essentially wants to add the
salaries divided by the number of
companies may be weighed by the number
of employees or the size of the company
or something so that's a very simple
computation but to get everybody
together to send to use the technology
they have the lawyers sign off on that
this is okay is huge problem and they
didn't manage to do it and this was you
know in what convinced I think these
companies to do it is at the end nobody
knew what their payment to women and men
was they knew what the average salaries
so they know what the benchmark is and
whether they're above or below and then
it was up to them to act on it so and so
since you're providing the information
go and do what you want then I think
that it's a lobbying actually said I saw
in some talk that they are now doing a
meet to kind of thing where people
complain in some place there's some and
then there is a secret place and if only
goes above ten complaints or something
about a particular individual then some
mechanism it's actually where these
people know of each other and then they
can decide what to do so this whole idea
of getting notification based on
aggregate of information is an
interesting idea what's another thing
that people have talked about they've
talked about educational outcomes so
what does I don't know how many people
here have children in college I have one
so much money
that is my scene but in a case here the
outcome is measure in terms of of money
how much money they make after they go
to college right and some colleges are
they more worth to go and not worth to
go what's the trade-off between how much
you put in and how much you get out and
of course the college is I want to give
you this information so the but it's a
clear case for doing some sort of
aggregate computation where you find out
what what average salaries are later and
I think that there's this whole
infrastructure we tack that learning
from tax records and student records to
try to correlate you know student
success and and then later profit and
this is a work again book Danno fees
from Estonia and this is a lot of this
work is done by this company okay then
as I mentioned before there is a
surveillance thing where we kind of use
the court structure this is paper with
some students at MIT where we use the
fact that in the court system there's
all these federal judges there might be
lots of them I don't know the numbers
that I've heard eight hundred or
something but there's only twelve
district court and you can sort of
utilize this hierarchical structure to
have the judges report only something
some share of what they do to these
twelve district courts and twelve
districts to do a multi-party
computation based on which they can
release statistics how many wiretaps are
really out there how many where types up
for crime white-collar crime pornography
crime whatever crimes people do and are
they effective because one interesting
question is that when the FBI comes and
says they want your keys you know a
reasonable question is to say okay based
on surveillance how many convictions
have you had and often they is an answer
that either they claim they don't know
or they don't want to answer because I
don't think it's that many but it would
be interesting to find out yes and this
is the kind of statistics that you might
be able to collect finally maybe
international cooperation you know some
platform you know the missing plane if
everybody got together and gave all
their satellite information maybe there
would be a better effort or faster
effort to find coordinates so I think
that's all I want to say except the
punchline is that
investing in basic research is a good
idea and and
and the argument is really the story
that I just told that you know if you
think about our say and sort of basic
research in 76 where would we be today
if we didn't invest in it okay where
we'll be you know in in going ahead
where are we going to be you know 2050
if we don't invest in research today I
think the question is that we don't want
to find out okay thank you I'm not gonna
take any questions we have a reception
upstairs
outside outside even better okay thank
you thanks everybody for coming